first a spending spree showdown in
washington president biden wants 3.5
trillion dollars in spending and more
than a trillion for infrastructure but
speaker pelosi delayed the vote because
of the division among the moderates and
the progressives in the democratic party
i'm going to work like hell
to make sure we get both these passed i
think we'll get them passed do you think
by thanksgiving sir do you think this
could be all done by thanksgiving
i think it'd be done by 2 27 a.m on
december come on i think we'll get done
planning time for it to be part of
changing the tax code for people next
year
all right after nancy pelosi delayed the
vote she wrote in a letter to democratic
colleagues quote more time is needed to
complete the task now democrats want
free community college for all illegal
immigrants they want spend of 12 billion
for government electric cars and 3
billion for tree equity yes you heard me
right moderates won't support the
spending bill progressives want all 3.5
trillion of it
the two wings of the party there's the
aoc bernie wing they want both bills and
they're going to hold the one hostage so
they get them both
the other more moderate side the other
they're very mad at kirsten cinema and
joe manchin they're the two democrats
who are holding up and they're mad at
them because they're not progressive
enough forgetting that they only got
elected because they're not progressive
because they're moderates
here's my question does spending more
money make you a better person or a
bigger moderate
all right sean duffy let's start with
you and pick up where bill maher left
off right obviously he's talking about
the moderates in the senate that are
going to be a hold out here but you've
got pelosi and biden saying nope we're
going to get this done it doesn't sound
like it's going to be three and a half
trillion because the votes aren't there
what does this look like when it's done
in october or november
well what does it look like when we
watch bill maher and go this is a guy
with some common sense who's a radical
progressive right
but i think you make a good point so joe
biden uh uh joe manchin has come out and
said listen i'm not spending more than
1.5 trillion dollars um that's put a a
pick in the balloon of a lot of the
liberals over in the house that want to
have this massive bill and the problem
here jackie is that nancy pelosi has
built up a lot of credibility over the
course of decades in congress she told
the moderates that if they voted for
this reconciliation package that was a
3.5 trillion
she would bring up their uh
infrastructure package on the 27th of
september well that date has come and
gone and she never brought it up for a
vote right so she's lost all kinds of
credibility let me just take a moment
and talk about these numbers we spent
trillions of dollars last year jackie on
coveted relief under president trump but
that money wasn't even spent and this
year democrats spent 1.9 trillion on
covet relief they want to spend 1.2
trillion on infrastructure and 3.5
trillion on
on this progressive new bill that's
going to give green new deal spending
and give us um redistribution that's
actually going to be a 5 trillion 5.5
trillion we're talking 8 trillion
dollars this year alone this is insanity
and just one last point on the
infrastructure bill only half of it is
for infrastructure and because they
didn't reform the way that we uh we we
do the permitting process you're not
going to build roads and bridges for 10
years there's no new roads and bridges
coming in america it's 10 years from now
right the three and a half trillion
we're talking about is that human
infrastructure if you will and to your
point sean we are living in an
environment of massive inflation right
now spending more isn't going to help it
at the moment but i want to switch gears
for a moment because lisa when we talk
about nancy pelosi she's been doing this
forever and even though she might have
lost a little credibility she's got a
lot of confidence in herself listen
i'm a
master legislator i am a strategic
politically astute leader i am uh
my uh
leadership is recognized by many around
the country
lisa what do you think she can do here
well she's also been in charge under
historic losses if you look at elections
like the 2010 midterm elections so maybe
she's a little too big for her bridges
here but look there's been all this heat
the progressives are pointing all their
ire at you know cinema and manchester
look they're not up for re-election
until 2024. do you think they care about
this political heat now the political
dynamics and headwinds are going to look
so different heading into the 2024
election they don't care but what i
think is interesting is if you look at
virginia which of course is the
governor's race which is going to be a
good bellwether for what the midterms
in 2022 next year are going to look like
what is terry mcauliffe been saying the
democrat there he has actually said the
3.5 trillion dollar price tag is too
high and democrats should just go with
the infrastructure bill so what does
that mean then if you look at democrats
who are running for reelection in the
midterms that have tough races when you
look at people like mark kelly maggie
hassan raphael warnock
catherine masto as well or really any
democrat running in a competitive
district in the house so i i think
democrats should actually you know maybe
slow their role here because they're
they're you know nancy pelosi could be
once again walking her party off a cliff
she sure could be and when it comes to
mansion and cinema of course they are
responding to what their constituents
want and that's the issue here tyrus i
want to get straight to you because one
and a half trillion floated by joe
manchin um it's still a lot of human
infrastructure to add to the spending
that we've already done but aoc says
even that much not enough listen
the bill passes
that is underfunded
that only gives a crumb
you get that crown
because when you only give some
and not all
then some people get nothing when you
tell me isn't something better than
nothing what i hear what you're actually
telling me isn't something for you
better yep yeah
is it something for you better
why don't you accept nothing so that i
can get something
all right so she's saying it's gotta be
all or nothing some would say that she's
being unreasonable there tyrus your
thoughts
well
when you say six on one hand
and five on the other
that makes four
you know
sometimes when you film on a phone it
looks small but when you're making a
speech and you can hear individual
people breathing that shows how much
real support she really has and the
second thing this is why you never ever
see anyone go up to a politician and go
thank you for your service because no
one thanks you for self-service and
that's exactly what the progressives are
about they're not about the american
people they know we have a bill which is
already high that we could pass the
first infrastructure bill but no because
they're not interested in infrastructure
they're not interested in fixing the
country they're interested in making
programs that their special interest
groups and friends can make money on i.e
electric cars spending for the
government and
i'm trying to understand this because
right now in this country everyone who's
here who's american citizen has friends
and family members losing small
businesses and restaurants can't stay
open but you want to make sure illegal
immigrants get a great education at a
junior college
yeah you bring up a great point just
confused we've got a lot of small
businesses that are suffering they can't
hire people even if they raise wages
because after the pandemic sean nobody
really wants to work anymore but another
issue here is really the split that
we've got in the senate right when it's
50 50 like this the democrats know even
the progressives know they only have a
limited amount of time to get things
done so they better figure out a way to
come together come up with a number that
works more than you know maybe it's more
than one and a half maybe it's less than
three and a half sean but they need to
do this now i mean that's the bottom
line well no i think that's a really
good point and as aoc says i'm not going
to take part of the pie i want the whole
pie well i'm sorry you have two chambers
one is in the house and they can get all
the votes in the house for this massive
spending but as you pointed out jackie
there's a 50-50 split in the senate and
you can't lose one senator so
a mansion and cinema hold a lot of cards
as to what the final deal will look like
and i i served in congress for for
almost 10 years and what's interesting
is you have people who think they're
really pure they're pure conservative or
they're pure liberal and they're not
about compromise well if you want to get
a hundred percent of everything that you
want whether it's in the congress or in
marriage you end up with getting nothing
the answer will be zero for you that's
why the congress was made up for people
to compromise and so the sooner aoc
recognizes that the sooner she gets to a
lower number which by the way even 1.5
trillion is massive and i disagree with
that number two yeah and compromise is
such an important word here remember
when biden ran he said he was going to
be a unifier he was going to bring both
sides together it doesn't look like it
so much right now all right we're gonna
have to leave it there guys so much for
the border though being closed how bad
the biden administration thinks it could
get at the border as new numbers show
how bad it already is we're gonna give
you those numbers coming up next